اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى من العسكريين الروس نتيجتها تصفيه
مركز انتشار له في مكيف كبدنيا الى 89
قتيلا وقال النائب الاول لرئيس الادارات
العسكريه السياسيه الرئيسيه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه ان التحقيقات الاوليه الى
ان استخدام الجنود للهواتف في الجوال رغم
الحضر كشف موقعهم من جانبه قال ناطق باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اين القوات الروسيه
تواصلوا مهاجمه محور دنياك
قضينا على اكثر من اربعين عسكريا اوكرانيا
في محوري كوبيانسك الى جانب مجموعتي
استطلاع الاوكرانيتين في مقاطعه خاركيف
وفي محور كلاسني لمن سقط اكثر من 120
للمزاعيه الروسيه الثقيله كما تستمر
قواتنا في مهاجمه محور الدنيا وقضت على
نحو 90 عسكريا اوكرانيا اما سلاح الجوي
فقد قضى على اكثر من 130 من المرتزقه
الاجانب في مدينه كرامتوسك